miss daphne bridgeton
who else has finished devouring
bridgerton we sure have and are ready to
talk about
undoubtedly one of the best parts yes
we're talking about phoebe denver do i
while the actress seemed to appear out
of nowhere
the truth is she's been working for over
a decade
so who is this mysterious talent that's
graced our screens
which celebrity is she very closely
related to
how about the trick that helps her get
into character when filming bridgerton
we've got all that and more so get ready
to learn
everything you need to know about our
favorite new female lead
you have no idea what it is to be a
woman
she may be only 25 years old but her
first tv role came when she was just
14. are you okay miss campbell denver
first graced the screen in the british
show
waterloo road the manchester-born
actress is the eldest of three and went
to school in stockport when she wasn't
busy on set that is
it's no surprise she is already so
successful denver is a true aries
filled with passion motivation and
confidence
the fact that she began acting
professionally at such a young age
didn't come as much of a surprise to her
parents my mother told me something
curious the other day
since the two are recognizable names in
the industry any coronation street fans
out there
denver's mom sally has been starring in
the long-running show as sally webster
since
1986. well he won't find out from me
her dad is also no stranger to showbiz
tim denover is a british academy
award-nominated screenwriter
now that is an impressive family the
actress is currently single but she was
dating fellow actor sean teal in 2017.
when she isn't busy acting she can
probably be found with her nose buried
in a book as a self-proclaimed bookworm
or watching a classic film like
breakfast at tiffany's or ferris
bueller's day off
denver is also a big fan of meditation
and practices sound healing
sounds like she knows how to balance
life and her work
yes brother i do
after her debut in waterloo road denver
did not slow down
her imdb is stacked with credits some
actors could only
dream of it makes sense that her
performance in bridgerton is so natural
since she's no stranger to period pieces
the actress previously did a tv version
of the three musketeers and a charles
dickens adaptation called dickensian
never mind while she had done period
pieces before
denver had always wanted to do a regency
era drama
we can see why and tell me why she seems
right at home on the show other earlier
credits include the british shows
prisoner's wives the village and snatch
in which she starred alongside one of
our other favorite english actors rupert
grint
denver's american tv debut was in the
show younger where she played an irish
girl living in new york i think the
baby's coming
with a steady list of credits to her
name and an incredible performance in
bridgerton
she is definitely a star on the rise she
reminded many people of other stars of
the screen
like kate winslet and sophie turner
since she has so many physical
similarities to the two
while she doesn't have any familial
connections to either we can definitely
see them playing relatives on screen
becoming an overnight sensation can
definitely be a shock to the senses
but denver has said that for her the
experience has been atypical since the
world is in isolation
we're sure that once the red carpets are
rolled out again we'll be seeing her
everywhere i had no idea
so how did phoebe denver go from
steadily working actress to an overnight
celebrity
it all began nearly two years ago in
february 2019
her first audition for bridgerton it may
come as a surprise to learn that the
actress didn't hear anything back for
about three months
once the creators finally got back to
her the process went at
lightning speed yes after she got the
call she went from meeting to meeting
and in chemistry reads with confirmed
cast members
finally she had a meeting in la with
shonda rhimes
yes the shonda rhimes
and the day after she was offered the
job what a whirlwind
once she was finally cast as daphne
bridgerton the work didn't stop
in fact it was only beginning she did
a wild amount of prep for the role when
she wasn't rehearsing
she could be found doing horse riding
piano dance
and etiquette classes if that weren't
already a lot on her plate
she also spent a lot of time in costume
fittings considering she has
a whopping 104 different dresses in the
show
should i ever want a different dress
being in such a huge production
definitely takes a lot of focus so to
help her get into character
phoebe denver makes playlists to listen
to seems like she has it all figured out
it's obvious she's
no stranger to the business we can't
talk about bridgerton without noting the
incredible chemistry dinavore has with
her dreamy co-star regent page
i am so sorry what the two actors credit
the amazing script for that
as well as the six weeks of prep they
had together before filming
not only that but an intimacy
coordinator was a key part of their
rehearsal process
denver has said that it was a
contributor to the magic and intimacy
scene in the show
with all that rehearsal and time to bond
their trust grew naturally and lends
itself to the powerful relationship they
have in bridgerton
i have a better idea
we're keeping our fingers crossed for a
second season
the chances seem pretty good since there
are eight books in the bridgerton series
the show was adapted from
if there is another season jennifer has
said that she hopes her character will
get involved with her elder brother
anthony's love life
we're definitely not opposed to seeing
more of actor jonathan bailey on our
screens
here's hoping we will get to see more of
both actors on screen
soon i should think so you are in my
seat
what an amazing person and actress we
just can't wait to see how her career
grows
we're keeping our fingers crossed for a
second season did you recognize her in
any other shows
what part would you love to see her play
next let us know what you think in the
comment section
make sure to click the like button and
hit subscribe so you don't miss a thing
from us here at the things